il faut que je change de chaises et bim
almost waneux depuis qu'on a fait cette
vidéo entre temps les choses ont changé
pour nous tous et toutes il y en a qui
ont eu des enfants y en a qui sont rendu
compte que ça y est ils avaient envie
d'avoir des enfants et en a que moi qui
se méfie toujours des enfants
moi rien n'a changé les gars ça me fait
toujours pas du tout envie et vous êtes
toujours nombreux à me dire quand est ce
que tu auras un enfant se briser je suis
pas envie de vider la poubelle me fait
pas évident et on s'appelait dit hold my
view ce box c'est un dérivé du fameux
all my pire vous savez c'est ça me
bouffe du du mâle alpha qu'elle a avec
sa bière et qui dit attends tu as ma
bière et qui va faire un truc de ouf
là c'est la même chose mais version
enfant là dedans on va voir plein
d'enfants faire affalés truc style est
parfois du tout mon style bref c'est un
peu comme ce qu'on avait fait à l'époque
sauf que ce ne sera pas du tout les
mêmes vidéos et comme pour ya un an vous
allez pouvoir regarder cette vidéo
mesurer votre sensibilité vis-à-vis des
enfants et donc possiblement votre envie
d'avoir ou non des enfants les mène sur
ta zéro en termes d'envié l'accord
exemple avec cette vidéo
non mais non mais non comment il arrive
à rire que vous ce mec arrive à rien je
serai de paralyser de peur à sa place
c'est pas parce que c'est un enfant que
ça résume à l'aise et je pense à la
rigolade non non non just one - mais
attend des mecs mais ça c'est ça c'est
un truc de torture je crois j'ai vu des
scènes de torture dans des films ou
espaces ça c'est une enfant de 7 ans qui
le fait instinctivement à son nounours
non mais c'est pas possible c'est les
parents pour taper une barque ont
demandé à leurs enfants de faire ça mais
oui c'est sûr il voulait faire des rt on
a tous tôt ou tard un besoin de rt dans
la nuit c'est pardonné un enfant
accroché à son smartphone s'est mis à
marcher à côté de quelqu'un qui n'est
pas son père ainsi génial c'est de la
balle les gars allez gallega légal et ce
qui si on vaut mieux que cet enfant skis
si on était en pleine discussion avec
des potes tout en regardant un téléphone
et on a continué cette discussion
croyant que la personne à côté de nous
et et nos potes alors que pas du tout
nos potes et trois mètres derrière tout
de suite un compteur qui montre le
nombre de gens qui ont vécu ce que je me
dis bah je suis un très mauvais youtuber
j'ai chaud oh là là je vais faire ce
geste
[Musique]
j'ai 65 ans je tiens ma brique de jus
pendant que je saute de cinq fois ma
hauteur mais il a craqué mais il a
complètement cramé laverie lui non mais
tu vois c'est ça ce stress que ça doit
être d'être parent je vis avec natsu je
les ai déjà dit non je sais je me répète
je m'en fous quand tu vois ton en faire
ça c'est rigolo quand tu vois qui se
relève et qui sourit mais il ya
forcément à ce moment-là ce moment là
ton coeur s'arrête ta vie s'arrête je
sais plus quoi faire
ça me terrifie samoa ce truc-là d'être
parent c'est tellement de stress mais
lukas aussi tellement de partage d'amour
d'entre elles - tellement d'amour c'est
hull et du tu lui apprends un peu la
ville va devenir tu as quel âge 55 ans
c'est chaud c'est vraiment facile oui
oui à la maquillage animal aux as un peu
bidon j'avoue là ton coeur c'était le
papa ou la maman prend ma brique de jus
pendant que je caresse tessin quoi y'a
ok il est adorable
écoutez moi bien il les adorait cette
petite faute de langage est adorable
aussi voilà voilà
quoi quoi quoi mais c'est quoi c'est un
fonds démoniaque la tam et c'est fou de
six jeunes faire la blague du à je me
suis blessée des mois je me suis blessé
et bah non c'est la blague que j'ai fait
dans la dernière ailleurs vidéo
activités manuelles là c'est [ __ ] de
fer instinctivement cette blague si
jeune âge et it happen bar gratuitement
en plus derrière en tout cas ça me
conforte dans l'idée de céder peste elle
ne sait pas que c'est une statue elle
veut juste l'aider
oh non c'est adorable sa suite ou non
non tiens mon jus pendant que je célèbre
mon but
[Musique]
ça va si vite les parents comment vous
faites une seconde non anticipation et
blanc deux dents cassées quoi je sais de
quoi je parle
tenez monju pendant que je souffre cette
bougie pas comment ça peut mal finir
impossible il est très proche il est
très proche
[Musique]
il est très proche
il va se brûler j'ai un réflexe de daron
mon dieu elle n'y arrive pas à souffler
et [ __ ] c'est marrant ça qu'à une
époque de la vie on ne sait pas souffler
à la technique de la paille
quel bon papa ça quel bon papa en vrai
la jeune comme quoi j'ai du mal avec ses
enfants
c'est que j'ai peur pour eux en fait je
suis stressée pour eux j'ai trop peur
qu'il leur arrive malheur qui se brûle
le nez là on souffle en touche je suis
stressé aurait dit mme stress je gère
très mal mon stress encore une bougie
l'isam stress il a eu tort
il a eu tort ouah quel homme
while et plus alpha que nous alors qu'il
a 23 ans de moins je suis impressionné
ah non non ça il va se cogner la tête
[Musique]
désole fairouz enfin je peux rire parce
que c'est un truc similaire mais arrivé
d'accord et je suis sûr qu'il a rien
vous savez les panneaux ne pas courir en
bord de piscine quand tu es jeune là
qu'il est respecté j'ai respecté jamais
et un jour j'ai glissé et je suis tombé
comme un pnj dans un jeu vidéo
les bras comme salon du corps comme ça à
est ici là je saignais très très fort
donc voilà je peux me permettre de rire
de ce petit enfant et deux innocemment
d'accord
tiens mon jus pendant que je fais peur à
cet enfant avec mon rire
ouais
[Musique]
l'adorable il est génial
ja parce qu'il a impulsées liot que je
mettais quand j'avais 20 ans et ensuite
parce que sa réaction elle et elle est
trop honnête je sais ça qu'il est mignon
j'avoue ok j'avoue non non non non en
fait des enfants ils ont vraiment des
réactions pur et c'est trop adorable ce
trou faire de mes chèques avec sa petite
soeur
oui mais c'est plus un fait place à un
kidnapping au lavage [ __ ] mais c'est
dingue ce réflexe de porter quelqu'un
d'autre à la tête direct au fond ils me
tuent les ampute un sacré talent et
guerre depuis quand faire une vidéo
réaction c'est faire du sport on était
au maire didier tellement changé moi ça
me tue de faire le mouv qu'un gars fait
quand il joue au tennis depuis trois
heures moi je suis regardé vidéo il est
un mais c'est fou ce truc de ne pas
avoir la peau dure là je trouve un bon
réflexe d'en rire le gars qui filme
comment il s'est retrouvé là dedans est
génial il a plus qu'à tout prendre sur
il fait ce genre il pleure il en panique
mais c'est juste parce qu'il s'est fait
griller mes envies d'aller se servir
l'asie
c'est un petit génie qu'est ce que c'est
que ça encore
quoi
mais ce n'est pas une manière de balader
son enfant mais il a cru c'était un
bagage cabine sont enfin là je cours en
bas pourquoi parce qu'il faisait un
caprice [ __ ] mais fait comme les chiba
son enfance et inchy pas des fois ils
s'allongent et ne veut plus avancer été
obligé de le porter c'est incroyable
tiens mon jus pour ce que je veux faire
un mini show au nom elle pleure c'est un
peu drôle quel courage est fait on
rigole mais quel courage
même à 20 ans ça je le fais pas j'ai
trop peur un nerf dans l'oeil les gars
doivent pas déconner tiens mon jus
pendant que j'attrape ça au nom et lui a
offert le meilleur tik tok ever au nom
génial
visa est un grand réalisateur lui si sûr
[Musique]
allez c'est bien ce que je pensais eh
bien écoutez j'espère que la vidéo vous
aura plu en vrai ils sont mignons des
enfants ils sont mignons un tout petit
peu con mais mignon qu'avez vous
ressenti devant ces deux osé assumer ce
que vous avez ressenti devant ces vidéos
lettre que vous êtes at il ressenti de
l'amour la compassion de la peur la
méfiance du stress dit il
qu'est-ce qui vous avez ressenti en fait
toute ma vie j'ai vu que des gens
trouvaient les enfants trop mignon et
parler tout tant d'enfants et autant
dire alors te raconte les enfants c'est
quand les enfants machin comme si
c'était une étape genre obligatoire de
la vie alors qu'en avril près du toucher
qu'un fils qui veut que tu vas fort
était stressé vis-à-vis de ça ne vous
mettez jamais de pression vis-à-vis de
ça vous faites ce que vous voulez c'est
votre vie plus moral comme ça non mais
ça parce que même au tournoi ya des gens
qui sont stressés par sa tourmente est
plus temps passe plus d'heures mais il
faut que j'ai des enfants sinon c'est
pas bien maintenant mais sinon quoi tu
fais ce que tu veux
bref merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo en
tout cas moi c'est ça n'a pas bougé par
rapport à l'année dernière c'est
vraiment je ressens tous pareils c'est
incroyable bravo à ceux qui vient
d'avoir des enfants bien évidemment
courage à ceux qui essaient d'en faire
et ouais ça va ou quoi les frérots
auprès de ceux qui veulent pas je vous
dis à bientôt c'est charles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]